the rock the guy has like six movies
coming out this year that we know of
which means when we're done with this
review we will be 1/6 of the way done
with his filmography for 2013 that's
crazy so let's get this going
[Music]
snitch no one likes a snitch so snitch
is the story of a guy played by the rock
whose son accepts a package from a
friend that's a bunch of narcotics and
I'll look at that he mailed it to him
which means the DEA totally pinches him
because dude don't send your drugs
through the mail really she / bottles
okay so this kid gets pinched he's gonna
spend ten years in prison the rocks like
that ain't happening how about this I
will go set up other drug dealers and
reduce my son sentence and then
hopefully you know the son just gets out
of jail and everyone lives happily ever
after now we have a movie be honest with
you I mean I enjoyed this movie it's
like the great be a lot of things like
the great bee wire or the great B
Breaking Bad or a great B other TV show
or a movie that I can't really think of
right now because it's 4:00 in the
morning the point is it's not like
cinematic a game but it is good
cinematic entertainment the rocks
actually really good in the movie there
are a couple scenes there's is one scene
where he's on the phone you could tell
he's trying to squeeze a tear and one
kind of it comes down to there but the
rock don't cry he tried to though he was
like this that's the best we got and his
tear just went and he freaked him out
the guy he has to show him the
underground world and made the
connections the dick from The Walking
Dead yeah that guy and he was actually
good in the movie too then he meets Omar
from the wire cuz oh my god or in this
movie rather he just kind of sits in a
chair in and talks Michael Kenneth
Williams is awesome though I like seeing
the guy every time he's on screen I'm
like it's badass
I suppose my biggest gripe in this movie
is the movie could have gone really
complex in awesome places but it's a
pretty simple premise and of course near
the end they're like all right we need
freeway chase scenes so those start
happening you're like this isn't as
interesting to me as the character
development has been I mean the movie
ends and you walk out going all right
Barry Pepper is in this movie funny
my brother and I were talking about this
guy like yesterday we were like you know
what's sad Barry Pepper you know what
happened to Barry Pepper Battlefield
Earth you know what he's done since not
much didn't Barry Pepper shows up in a
movie that day you know what else is
awesome that time I met Nathan Fillion
nothing weird I didn't ask for someone
classy like Natalie Portman to fall from
the sky or any one of the big titty
desperate from piranhas three
double-deep know Nathan Fillion
man-crush always Trump's in the end I
will say snitch is good entertainment
it's not you know summer blockbuster and
it's not going to be up for any Oscars
or anything like
but it's good February entertainment I
will say snitch is a good time no
alcohol required no it's not a piece of
look at that it's actually not a
bad movie all right so the rocks had a
pretty diverse career what is your
favorite movie with the rock in it what
is the worst movie with the rock in it
whatever they are comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]